>> LASSEN: Let me talk about the Wave Server
and Store in a Wave in a Box. So, yes, so
a quick outline, I'll talk about the Wave
bus whereby the Wave server component--when
I say Wave server here, it's sort of a narrow
sense of the certain components in the system
and the Wave bus which is the interface by
which it talks to the rest of the system.
And then I'll talk about data structures in
there, the Wave map, the wavelet container;
explain how the mechanics of applying a delta
with operational transformation, et cetera.
Then I will explain the commit notices and
how that sort of sets the requirements for
the Wave Store implementation--for a persistent
Wave Store implementation. I won't have a
lot to say about the index but--and then I'll
explain how the Federation side of the Wave
server works and then end up by binding to
where the source code is and explain sort
of the current status of what's working and
what isn't, and some of the next--some of
the things that--the next things we should
be doing to it. So this is Alex's diagram
from yesterday. So I think he called it the
server core of that--the big box above the
Wave--above the data store and behind the
Wave Bus. So this is what is meant by the
Wave server in this talk and it's indeed called
the Wave server in the source code. And the
Wave Bus is what connects it to the client
front-end and the robot gateway. These
clients of the Wave Bus, they are the ones
that consume the deltas that are going through
the system and that they are the ones who
update the Waves and submits delta into the
Wave server. So the Wave Bus, I think in the
source code it's called both--is split across
two interfaces, one called Wave bus, another
called Wave provider. But I think it's useful
to think on this as one. This is the interface
between the Wave server component and the
rest of the system. And it allows the clients
to subscribe to all the--all the traffic in
the system that the Wave server broadcasts
to the clients. And the traffic is the deltas
have applied and commit notices which I'll
return to but it means--so, yeah, commit notice
means that you get a guarantee that something
has been persisted. The--and then the clients
can call some methods on this interface. They
can submit a delta. They can request a snapshot
of a wavelet and the--they can look at the
past deltas in the history--delta history
of the wavelets and they can be given a Wave
ID, they can ask for it to look up the set
of wavelets in a Wave. As I look through the
code and information, I start to realize that's
not readily implemented but it should be.
And I should take a closer look at exactly
how client front-end works. I think we--the
thing is that we don't have user data wavelets
and private replies and so on that are turned
on in the Wave in a Box client yet; therefore,
we haven't--this concept of discovering the
wavelets in the Wave have not been relevant
yet. So the advantage of this particular diagram
here and the division of labor and that is
represented here between the Wave server and
the client front-end is that the Wave server
is not dealing with the session states of
the clients that are connected to the system.
It just sends all the--everything has happened,
sends it out on the Wave bus and then the
client front-end system manages the client
state. So that's a nice simplification here
down in the boiler room of the Wave server.
Because, you know, all the--all the traffic
is broadcast to everyone, it means that access
control is--some of this shared--so the Wave
bus clients are trusted to components that
have to engage in the access control. They
are responsible for performing access control
for their clients. So the data structures
inside the Wave server component is there's
a Wave map that--it maps Wave IDs to waves,
so to speak, and where the Waves are represented
by a map from wavelet IDs to wavelet containers.
A wavelet container contains the states of
a wavelet. So the most important part is the
delta history, as through the system diagram
here later to explain that. The delta history
is a list of contiguous deltas starting from
version zero. Each delta has a version--the
version where it applies that and it still
has one or more operations. So these little
circles inside are operations and the triangles
are the deltas as we see how the version numbering
follows the number of operations inside the
deltas. So now that every number is a valid
version, only those have fall on a delta boundary.
And then another--the rest is--and then see--so
this--then we also maintain a snapshots of
the wavelet states, so this is something I
also described yesterday. So this is a one--when
you apply all these deltas one by one to the
empty wavelet states, then you end up with
the current wavelet state which is the ordered
set of participants. It's in the map from
the document IDs to documents or blips and
the lib bit of metadata like the creator,
the name of the author of the first--the delta,
the creation time which is the timestamp of
the first delta, and the current version,
you might be able to say. Then we maintain
like the last modified time and so on, which
is the timestamp of the last delta. It was
all derived from the data in the deltas and
then we maintain the last committed version
which has to do with this commit verses that
I'm going to return to. So, when a client
of the Wave bus, say, the client front-end
of the robot proxy, submits a delta, it--such
a delta--so this--let me see. I have this
diagram here. So a submitted delta is one
of the red ones. They're coming in from a
client of the Wave bus. In the delta, there's
an author, there's one or more operations
and then there's the target version. So in
the diagram, it's the downwards route, red
arrow, it's the version within the history
of the wavelets that--the version of the wavelet
that the client was thinking of when it formulated
this delta. Now, the concurrency control in
the system with the operation transformation
means that the client could've seen one thing
and thought of applying a delta there, but
the world has moved on. Others came in concurrently
and came first added these deltas. So here
in this picture, the leftmost red delta is
the one that the client was thinking of. The
last two deltas here in the delta history
were things that arrived that the client hadn't
seen when it came with this delta. Then by
operation transformation, this delta is transformed
to--across these two deltas. And once it's
transformed opposite at the target version
points at the current version of the wavelet,
then this transformed delta can be applied.
So these deltas at the bottom are transformed
deltas that--so they look very similar to
a submitted delta. They have a list of operation
and author. The version of a delta down here
is the one that they would--they would actually
apply that and then they had this extra field
or application timestamp, the server timestamp
at which time the transformation was complete
and the delta was applied. And once it's a--so
the server does operational transformation
and by the end of the checking sees that the--that
makes sense with these, so for instance, if
it's a--let's say, it's add participant, you
can only add a participant if the participant
wasn't already there or--and the test we can
say wasn't exactly well-formed. If it's a
document operation, it has to be well-formed
in the way I described yesterday. If it's
all good, it's applied and then it's broadcast
on the Wave bus server. Everybody learns that
the delta history has grown. Yeah. So the
current implementation has the Wave Map and
the Wavelet Container is all held in memory,
so that's nice and simple. But of course,
not super useful that only Wave disappear
when you restart your server. So, we should
assist the Wave data in the--inside the Wave
Server. And then, so that our couplet patches
with implementations of persistence, one from
March by Anthony Watkins and Steve Baker;
and another one from June by Vaclav Sykora.
And so, yeah, so it's a little bit--little
bit unhappy story about what has happened
to these patches. So we messed up the code
review of Anthony's earlier in the year and
then--and so it was hanging around it. But
in August, when we put more resources on Wave
in a Box, we took a look at these patches
again and then we communicated with Anthony
and Steve, and came up with--and decided that
we would piecemeal and get persistence in.
So, first to see, Linnux took just the certificate
store. I'll describe that in a moment what
a certificate store is. It's now--has a persistent
augmentation in using MongoDB. Then Joseph
and I, and Frederick Goubri wrote up a design
for a file-based Wave Store and so--and I'll
show that to you in a moment. And let me do
that now. So, what am I supposed to click
here. Yes. The--yes, actually there's one
thing. Let me--I'll come back to this slide,
but let me just say a few words about Commit
notices. So, this is to understand exactly
how persistence is intended to work and how
it works within the Google Wave Production
System. And so, we decided to broadcast these
applied deltas immediately when they're applied
and not wait for them to be persisted. And
then on the--both on the Federation protocol
and the time server protocol, a commit notice
is sent then as a follow-up notice that when
later the delta is persisted. The purpose
of this was to optimize the agency. We wanted--we
believe that it was a key part differentiator
that the live typing was really live and that
you would see things happen instantly, that
also spelling corrections and everything would
just--would come with a minimum delay. And
furthermore, so once you go this route, you
quite efficiently hide the latency of the
actual rights and there you can sort of start
patching rights on the Wave server to gain
some efficiencies in the--in storage access.
And, so there's a tradeoff here, the more
you delay the right and the more you patch,
the bigger you grow the window where you could
have a crash and you can lose that data that
you have told everybody about. And that concept
that this data is turning around the system
that there might be losses is a drawback to
this approach. And so it acts--complex to
the protocol, the very existence of these
commit notices and then what is the client
supposed to be doing with them. And so, it
has actually caused us a number of problems
and we're not entirely sure whether it was
given out to tell to your experience whether
that was--it was--it was a good choice to
make. So one of the things that we've had
problems with is cache invalidation edit.
We were sloppy and cached just the most recent
data running through the system rather than
be disciplined about only caching. The things
we knew to be committed and that has given
us a number of problems. So the way it can
work, you know, if you are disciplined about
only caching committed data, the system can
be made to work. The--one of the things that
makes it work is that the client buffers the
deltas after they have been--the deltas that
it has sent to the server, it holds on and
waits for them to be committed and keeps the
applied deltas. Its own applied deltas around
until it gets the commit notice. And if the
connection drops and the Wave server has crashed
and lost the data, then it goes into--it activates
some recovery logic where it tries to--when
we reestablish the connection, it tries to
find out what's the state of the wavelet on
the server. And if it then can determine that
the server has lost the deltas that it at
once applied, then it reapplies them. So,
we're sort of halfway there with the--with
the code that you'll find in the client-server
protocol under the concurrency control in
the concurrency control package. And so we
have some--there's some ways it could be improved
and be pretty robust, but it's sort of--there's--one
of the place where it falls down is it has
been actual concurrency so that the data is
lost from multiple clients, deltas that have
been transformed against each other; then
the current recovery logic comes up short.
Anyway, so the commit notices is key to understanding
how the Wave Store should work. So let me
go to the Wave Store assigned here, which
is up on the site pages. So a key requirement
to--so, you know, the commit notice tells
everybody that now you can rely on this having
recent permanent storage, then the Wave Store
should honor that. And so in terms of database
terminologies, this is a question of durability.
Can you say that something has been durably
stored? So that made us--when we took a closer
look at MongoDB, it actually doesn't promise
that in a single server configuration in there.
So the first thing, you know, doing--using
MongoDB, as Anthony had done, but then if--in
order to get a first improvisation where we
can be clear about the correctness of the
solution, we decided to go with a file-based
system instead. So, the Java file APIs has
a concept of durable storage, what's called
force a file to disk and then you know that
it has reached a persistent storage. So, let's
see. So that--if you put things directly in
files, then it looks like this. So,
the design--the file-based design here says
that there's a file per wavelet with the deltas
in them. So here, let's say we have--in the
Wave Store, we have two waves, food.com with
W plus something here and another in here,
bar.com something. This and--so let's say
we have two wavelets here in the first one,
the conversation wavelet and user data wavelets
then each wavelet has one file with deltas
where the deltas--the transformed deltas are
stored back to back. They are--then put in
a directory structure here where there's a
directory per Wave. And then because these--too
many--to be absolutely sure that we have some
filenames that are clean in every file system,
we were conservative and took the Wave ID
and in UTF8 and took the device and hex coded
them up into an ASCII string here, and similarly
with the Wavelet IDs for the delta files.
Then there's--the two, okay--so this way,
you can look it up right to the Wave Store;
does a directory look up to find the wavelets
in the--in the Wave by looking at the filenames.
The two files per wavelets, one is--oh man,
that looks terrible, the background. Yeah.
If that's impossible to see, let's go to the--go
to the design doc. So, the delta's file is
a--has a file header with some version
information to--so we know the format and
then there's a header and a body. The header,
it just says what the sizes of the components
in the body is. And in the body, we have two
things; the applied delta which is [INDISTINCT]
delta where there are some federation information
that we've come to now and then there's the
transformed delta that we talked about before.
And then, for efficiency, there's also an
index file. I'm not going to describe that
in detail so that's--so then that allows for
efficient indexing of the positions within
the file where the deltas are. So, let me
go back here. So, where we are with this is
that the--let's see, Joseph has implemented
the delta store that rise out these files.
We--it's not yet hooked up to the Wave server,
the Wave server and wavelet container classes
in the Wave server, so it's not operational
yet, but we're getting there. So, there are
some question marks here about inbox and search.
We haven't arrived at the design for these
things yet, so it's probably good I just shut
up about it. There's some thoughts about it
in the design doc and we have some ideas but
we're very open to inputs here. All right.
Let me quickly run through federation. The--and
let me just see. I could also save the rest
for the federation talk in the afternoon.
I'm already running over time. I just want
to say--let me just say--talk about it very
briefly. So, here again is a diagram with
the Wave server and the Wave bus. On the--the
Wave server also talks to XMPP server, a federated
instance of Wave in a Box also talks to XMPP
server and federates with other Wave servers
out there in the cloud. What it does on the
XMPP site is that it depends on whether a
wavelet is hosted by this Wave server or whether
it's hosted somewhere else. So for local wavelets,
wavelets whose wavelet ID--so with the reds
here--is the--so each line here is a wavelet
name consisting of wavelet ID--Wave ID followed
by a wavelet's ID. So the domain name in the
wavelet ID says where it's hosted and it--let's
say that this is the Wave server for foo.com
then these first four wavelets hosted at--that
it hosts a local. And for a local wavelet,
it does exactly what we just described and
then it--for federation,
it basically publishes this Wave bus to--or
XMPP to other federated servers. So it's--it
looks up all the participants--the domain
set on participants in the wavelet and then
it sends the traffic on the wavelets out to
those domains that it finds, so on, XMPP.
And then it accepts that they--the Wave server
from those domains, they can come and submit
deltas from those participants, the remote
participants and they can come in there to
make history requests to learn about the past
history of the wavelet. And so, for a remote
wavelet, so here's the one here at the bottom.
So that's hosted by bar.com. Well, for such
a thing--for such a wavelet, the Wave server
for the foo.com Wave server works basically
as a caching proxy. It serves up this Wavelet
for its local Wave bus clients and it keeps
a local copy of all the wavelet state that
it notes that it serves up to them. And it
then receives from the hosting, from bar.com,
the hosting Wave server or XMPP. It receives
that delta sets is the bar.com broadcasts
to it and it then follows them to the--its
local Wave bus. And then when local clients
submit deltas and instead of--so then foo.com's
Wave server doesn't do the operations transformers
on it. It just follows it to XMPP to the host
server and that way, it sort of works as a
proxy between--for the local clients towards
the actual host of the wavelet. I'll save
all these signatures and search stuff for
the federation talk. And yeah, so I won't--already
mentioned persistence and indexing as two
things that are work in progress. So the history
of the Wave in a Box Wave server which was
once called Fed One, so it was done quickly
for a particular event in July last year,
and so it's good that it's simple. It's not
a lot of craft that has build up, but it's
also too simple in places. The error handling
is too simplistic and we need some more unit
tests to make it easier to work with a code
base. And yeah, then that--apart from persistence
indexing, there are a couple of other things
that we should be doing for indexing. Would--we
should enhance the Wave bus interface so that
you can reliably deliver messages that delta
is across of the Wave bus. It doesn't work
to index if you--if you only index a Wave
when you log in, things don't crash. So we
have some ideas for how to do that that borrows
from what we did in the production system,
but I can share those, you know. If you want
to know about that, I have to share more about
that. Then, we are too lax about enforcing
certain constraints on wavelets so that we
should be policing a couple of things. We
had a system of police of clauses that were
running inside the Wave server that--doing
that in the production system and we should
probably do the same for the Wave in a Box
server. And then, yeah, that's certain efficiency
and scalability things that are not there
that will be useful to work on once we have
a feature complete. And yes, and I'll--I think
I'll skip the code walkthrough. So Joseph
did explain where some of this code is located.
Basically, all of this is inside the Wave
server package plus one or two classes in
the persistence package. And I'm happy to--all
those coming days I'm around and if you want
to know more, please come and ask. Questions?
Yes?
>> What is the pros and cons and possibilities
about upgrading a server into a more sophisticated
companion like the Wave logic server or web
sphere or...? Where do you actually get some
of new things like policing management, security
and user management [INDISTINCT]? Why did
you chose sort of not to do that? Are there
any reasons why they stayed away from doing
that in the future or to look at potential
doing this?
>> LASSEN: So, I'm rather ignorant about these
things. So it's possible that--so I should
repeat your question. So, yeah, your question
is...
>> You know, why not host that, you know,
you know [INDISTINCT], you could make the
server essentially a JCA or something? I mean,
adapt a transaction or adapt a [INDISTINCT]
and a couple of other things [INDISTINCT]
in Wave bus [INDISTINCT] clients to a JCA
framework for example.
>> LASSEN: Yeah, so the question is why not
build the Wave server in a JCA container that
has many of the features that we need here
and of something of that nature? And so that's
in part by, let's see, the historical routes
where we wanted to do a barebones simple system
where you could see enter into where the bits
was traveling through the system and in part
our [INDISTINCT] because we're not very well-versed
in these things. I can't give an informed
answer to that. Okay. So I ran overtime, so
let's move on to, question?
uestion is why not build the Wave server in
a JCA container that has many of the features
that we need here and of something of that
nature? And so that's in part by, let's see,
the historical routes where we wanted to do
a barebones simple system where you could
see enter into where the bits was traveling
through the system and in part our [INDISTINCT]
because we're not very well-versed in these
things. I can't give an informed answer to
that. Okay. So I ran overtime, so let's move
on to,